The announcement was a long time coming, if
you believe the rumor mill: The US has officially
accused Chinese telecom giant Huawei of a
bevy of crimes.
A grand jury in New York has returning indictment
alleging 13 additional crimes committed by
Huawei, it's CFO, its affiliate in Iran and
one of its subsidiaries here in the United
States.
The criminal activity alleged in this indictment
goes back at least ten years and goes all
the way to the top of the company."
The US justice department accuses Huawei's
top brass of using a Hong Kong based shell
company to funnel telecommunications equipment
to Iran in violation of international sanctions.
Investigators also accuse Huawei's engineers
of stealing trade secrets from cell phone
provider T-Mobile, including robotics plans
used in T-Mobile's cellphone testing.
The US' is also seeking the extradition of
Huawei CFO MENG WANZHOU for her roll in the
alleged sanction violations.
She was arrested in Canada late last year
in connection with the US' investigation.
Huawei has long been suspected of having close
ties to the Chinese government.
A cause for concern for some international
observers.
However both the company and the Chinese government
deny the accusations.
Just as the foreign ministry said, with no
evidence, they're using their state power
to discredit and attack designated companies.
This sort of behaviour is unfair and immoral.
The charges are likely to throw a fresh spanner
in the works.
Washington and Beijing are set to reopen
trade talks
over
their simmering
trade
conflict later this week.